[Music]
[Music]
it was the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
his first royal swore as a family with
Megan and Archie joining Harry who was
returning to Southern Africa a place
that's always been close to his heart a
huge media pack had traveled with them
on a tour that would end up defining
their relationship with the press
the couple flew into Cape Town with a
far from traditional start to their
Royals for arriving in the nyunga
Township known as the murder capital of
South Africa the celebrations were laid
on by those trying to tackle growing
levels of violence against women and
children and issue the Duke and Duchess
jointly addressed
I want you to know for me I am here with
you as a mother as a wife as a woman
as a woman of color and as her sister
[Music]
there was a side of my anger they were
never going to see because of security
fears and people they would never meet
who shared their beliefs that future
generations deserve amounted development
project for for building people to build
houses and whatever then the crime will
the Duke and Duchess toward the district
six museum to learn about the work to
reunite members of the community we've
been separated during the apartheid we
know they have huge respect for the late
President Nelson Mandela his
granddaughter in delica told us their
willingness to speak out against
inequality is vital from repairing torn
relationships from the past to
preventing them in the future
Harry and Megan met up with waves for
Change an NGO giving young people mental
health services through local surf
mentors in a joint interview they told
us it's an issue the world still needs
to wake up to what do you think is the
most pressing global issue when it comes
to dealing with the stigma around mental
health which still continues in so many
places today they're just getting people
to talk talk about it and talk to each
other right and you see that matter
where you are in the world you're in a
small community or a Township if you're
in a big city it's that everyone is
dealing with a different version of the
same thing globally I think there's a
bit of a consciousness crisis and so the
fact that we are able to be here
together and see on the ground so much
good work that's being done just because
people are willing to talk to each other
about it and someone's willing to listen
is huge everyone has experienced trauma
all likely experience trauma summit at
some point during our lives we need to
try and not eradicate it but to learn
from previous generations so that we
don't so that it's not a perpetual cycle
and I think what's amazing here is just
in a day and so they've been through it
and we can learn so much Megan hasn't
given any interviews like this since
they got engaged it obviously appreciate
the global impact they can have together
which is why they started the tour by
talking about violence against women so
we've done our best to try and keep
track of what's been going on but you
know South Africa was was always going
to be all this Africa tour was always
going to be fantastic
we've been looking forward to coming to
visit Cape Town her first visit I love
this place and again meeting the people
the energy the fun again the positive
the positivity the optimism and the hope
of course everyone was looking forward
to meeting
Archie mountbatten-windsor who at five
months old didn't have any official
royal engagements but he was given the
warmest of welcomes by Archbishop
Desmond Tutu who couldn't help but give
him a kiss and seemed very taken with
Megan to
[Applause]
but this was also a huge moment for the
waiting cameras the first time we'd seen
Archie since they arrived in South
Africa and his biggest photo call yet
inside there was a chance to talk about
their shared desire to help young people
a passion that's only grown for Harry
since becoming a dad it might be their
first family tour but they wanted the
focus to be on their work Megan got
straight back to it
fisting a charity called mothers to
mothers that helps women living with HIV
later in the tour she'd explained just
what her new role means to her well the
Commonwealth is a very diverse place
right with 53 countries and so being a
part of this family and the platform
that comes with that is an incredible
responsibility that I take really
seriously and I think for us it's just
been a really special trip because you
get to see when you're focusing on the
causes that are really important to us
you can see the impact is good and it
feels meaningful for Harry it was time
to leave the family behind in Cape Town
with us following him for African
countries 5,000 miles in five days our
first stop was Botswana and a tree
planting like no other
this summer he has been accused of
preaching on environmental issues after
using private jets it didn't stop him
from wanting to send a message to world
leaders and give his backing to Greta
Thornburg as he helped other children
plant trees to bring the forest back to
life in chobe national park science and
facts that has been around for the last
30 maybe 14 years and it's only getting
stronger and stronger
I generally I don't understand how
anyone in this world who ever we are you
us children leaders River it is no one
can deny science otherwise we live in a
very very troubling world it is the
wildlife that's kept him coming back to
Botswana we joined him on an anti
poaching patrol
the truth may be just as relentless when
it comes to cramming in the engagements
but it certainly feels a world away from
the media scrum that we saw in Cape Town
and he is a chance for Prince Harry to
really focus on those causes that matter
to him in a place who's so close to his
heart it is a country he admits has
given him so much especially following
the death of Princess Diana
[Music]
97-98 straight off when one died so it
was a nice place to get away from it all
but now I feel deeply connected our next
destination was a sandy runway in
Jericho in Angola with a few problems
with our landing you realize that we are
literally in the middle of nowhere but
this is what I wasn't expecting if we
turn around you can see this huge crowd
has turned out just to see Prince Harry
and that is partly because of the legacy
that his mother left behind is a country
she visited in the year that she died to
draw attention to the dangers of after a
night camping it was an early start as
we made our way to alive minefield site
in charge of the detonator it took just
seconds the explosion marking one less
land mine in angola Prince Harry had
come to see the painstaking work that
goes on here to clear the thousands of
mines left by the Civil War as a boy in
1997 he would have seen pictures of his
mother Princess Diana dressed in the
same safety kit visit just months before
she died that changed the way the world
looked at land mines a campaign now
taken on by her son land mines are an
unhealed scar of war by clearing the
land mines we can help this community
find peace and with peace comes
opportunity Angola still has one of the
world's highest levels of land mines
with 1,200 sites that still
need demining in a new project 50
million pounds is being spent by the
Angolan government to clear two national
parks protecting local people the
wildlife and making it safe for tourists
this is just one of over a hundred and
fifty landmine sites they're trying to
clear in this small part of Angola and
while it was important for Prince Harry
to come here and acknowledge the
important work that they're doing it was
never going to be the most poignant part
of his journey in the town of wanbo he
would make a moving visit to what's
become known as Princess Diana Street
now a busy road of houses businesses and
a school is here those pictures were
taken of his mother in a minefield radio
and FAL de Mar were his hosts we were
women actually to meet Prince
[Music]
bah-bah-bah my dream used to see this
job finished in another reminder of his
mother's visit he met Sandra tataka he
became known around the world when she
met Diana twenty-two years ago in a
hospital named after her he met with
young patients who'd lost limbs her
legacy Prince Harry knows won't be
complete until every landmine is gone as
he fights another battle his mother also
had to go through the boundaries between
Royals and the press as Harry was flying
around Southern Africa Megan had stayed
back in Cape Town and there was one very
important visit she wanted to make the
photo on their Instagram account showing
her leaving a ribbon of solidarity where
a student was murdered last month
nineteen-year-old you Nene
and what Jana was raped and killed after
going to collect a parcel her body was
then dumped at the Kyle Isha Township
her death has led to protests across
South Africa this month the president
described the country as one most unsafe
places in the world to be a woman
simpler lae was one of those who
organized the demos and welcomes Megan's
support it's good for someone from of
that magnitude or people that are
high-profile to also help us in fighting
this issue I think it can't be an issue
that one part of society fights but it's
something that who only to come together
in as we flew on to Malawi Harry was
bringing with him his wife's feminist
message visiting Nellie cool eCollege
we're a partnership between the UK and
Malawi is helping girls to stay in
school they couldn't have been more
excited to see Harry who is a big
supporter
but there was another guest on the line
from Cape Town you cannot begin to
express how valuable and vital that work
is we're just incredibly proud to be a
part of it
I wish I could be with you so happy I
can't wait to hear more
[Music]
Fatma Frank who is one of the first in
her community to go to secondary school
she's now a role model for others and
training to be a teacher
I lost net worth - when I was named so
it was difficult for my grandparents to
pay me extra fees so cope it supported
me I was about to leave school and then
they come in and somewhat didn't me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
women's rights is a relatively new cause
for the prince but we were heading for a
place that he's been to many times
before a remote airstrip and difficult
landing for our pilots all to get us
into Lee one-date National Park as the
president of the African parks he's been
here privately and you can see why in
Malawi poverty in the high international
price of ivory is one of the reasons for
poaching
but the British Army and local Rangers
are working to stop it in a project that
Harry helped to set up and it is working
with no elephants or rhino killed here
in the past five years speaking out so
passionately means that Prince Harry has
got his critics for saying this but I
think now in today's what I think is
more acceptable but everything is is in
balance
we're the only thing that's putting
everything out of balance it is we are
literally driving ourselves as we
approach the last day of the tour his
views on how he and his wife been
treated became very clear Harry just
quickly that's short conversation what
do you hope to achieve through it
[Music]
that way it's important for you to come
here and talk to them and then the Duke
released this announcing they were
launching legal action against a UK
paper in his statement he said my wife
has become one of the latest victims of
a British tabloid press that wages
campaigns against individuals with no
thought to the consequences a ruthless
campaign that has escalated over the
past year throughout her pregnancy and
while raising our newborn son he added
though this action may not be the safe
one it is the right one because my
deepest fear is history repeating itself
I've seen what happens when someone I
love is commoditized to the point where
they're no longer treated or seen as a
real person I lost my mother and now I
watched my wife falling victim to the
same powerful forces the story they
filed the complaint about a letter
written by Megan to her father after he
didn't attend their wedding today's
statement is really unprecedented we
have seen strongly wedded statements
from this couple in the past but I don't
think we've ever had something quite so
personal quite such a personal attack on
sections of the media clearly Harry is
absolutely furious about this Prince
Harry
has spoken about the impact it had on
him watching his mother Princess Diana
being pursued by the press this time he
isn't blaming photographers but says for
select media this has become a game
their visit to a township in
Johannesburg to talk about youth
unemployment was overshadowed by Tall he
didn't talk about it publicly but did
say he'd always fight for what's right
we will firmly stand up for what we
believe we are fortunate enough to have
a position that gives us amazing
opportunities and we will do everything
that we can to play our part in building
a better world the timing of this
statement is extraordinary when you
think they've had such a successful tour
and many saw this is not tunity for them
to turn things around after what has
been a difficult summer of headlines
this isn't Prince Harry just taking on
the mail on Sunday he is going into
battle with a whole section of the UK
press his words had taken the attention
away from the important diplomatic work
expected of them like meeting South
Africa's president we understand the
Queen and Prince Charles had been told
about it excuse me can I just ask you
what your thoughts had and Prince Harry
statements we don't know if they agreed
with Harry's decision to publish his
attack on the press as the couple were
meeting Nelson Mandela's Widow grasa
Michelle we spoke to his granddaughter
in Dilek er about the pressures of being
part of a world famous family it also
gives you a greater voice and a
credibility because of where you come
from but the flip side of that is that
it overshadows you because we have these
iconic families they tend to swallow up
alive that you can't have an opinion
even if you have an opinion if it goes
against the grain of what the family is
saying especially if you are non
conformist like the juries and I am and
oftentimes you commit a collision costs
a whoops she shouldn't have said that
because the grandfather wouldn't have
said it but forgetting that ultimately
you're a human being you are you
parts of this ten-day trip have been a
tour de force for the couple a chance
for Megan in particular to shine setting
up a battle with the press may not have
been the wisest way to finish it even if
they do feel under attack
[Applause]